GOOD MORNING GOING TO BRING THE
ASSEMBLY.
GOOD MORNING WILL BRING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO
ORDER MATTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
JONES SAWYER. HERE PRESIDENT
LACKEY HERE.
CARILLO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
ORANGE PRESIDENT WOULDN'T TAKE A
VOTE ONLY ITEM OUT OF ORDER.
SO I MY PHONE KNOWS ACTION.
I AM.
I AND IT IS OUR MOTION.
GREAT.
NETFLIX CALLED ROLE AB TWENTY TO
FORTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
JONES SAWYER ITEMS ARE AYE
LACKEY.
MIKEY I CARILLO CANNELLA AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSED.
THANK YOU.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE MR LOW HERE.
I GUESS WE CAN BEGAN WITH.
THE TWO MEMBER COMMITTEE MY.
ACR ONE NIGHT SEVEN JONES
SAWYER AND ACR TWO ONE NINE
JONES SAWYER.
PASSED THE GAVEL TO.
SELECT IS GONE รณ. DEMME'S
MISTER KILEY GETS.
TO SEE IF.
I THINK OVER. YEAH IT'S ON THE
SHOW.
THERE'S NO FAVORITISM.
MISTER JOHN SIR WHICH ITEM WILL
YOU BE AT PRESENTING FIRST ACR
ONE NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU YOU MAY PROCEED ARE
ACR ONE NINE SEVEN ENCOURAGES
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MOVE
AWAY FROM THE USING. FROM USING
THE TERM AT RISK TO LABOR ARE
MOST WILLING TO USE THE TERM AT
RISK HE'S USED TO LABEL CHILDREN
WHOSE ENVIRONMENT INCREASES
THEIR CHANCES OF ACADEMIC
FAILURE. DRUG ABUSE AND
INVOLVEMENT IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
DISK TERM COME FROM A MINDSET OF
DEFICIT DEAF FOCUSES ON WHAT
CHILDREN LACK IN ORDER TO.
SEE MANY EDUCATORS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS RECOGNIZE THE POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF USING THIS
LABEL ARE NOW USING TO STRENGTH
BASED TERM AT PROMISE.
THE STATE SHOULD.
PICTURE BUT CAPITALIZE BOMB ALL
ON ALL OUR CHILDREN PROMISE FOR
SUCCESS MOVE DEVELOP POST TO AT
RISK FAILURE. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT MEASURE HAVE WITH ME.
YOU LOOK LIKE PAMELA I'M NOT PAM
I'M LEARNING OKAY I HAVE
ATTORNEY. HERE FROM DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT. LOW FIFTIES BUT DE%
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OF EDUCATION.
OR.
NO ERNIE SO WAS DIRECTOR OF
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR SI. A TECH
MEMBERS ARE RESPECT LAST WEEK.
I VOTE.
THANK YOU AND AND VERY QUICKLY I
ALSO THE PRIVILEGE OF OF BEING
THE EXECUTIVE DECK DIRECTOR FOR
THE REACHING OUT PROMISED IN
ASSOCIATION.
AND WE'VE A OF TAKEN ON THAT
THAT THAT THAT PROMISE MANTLE
BECAUSE WE AS AS THE MEMBER
EXPLAINED I'M REALLY SEE THIS
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN THE WAY
THAT WE PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WE PROVIDE SERVICE.
TO OTHER TEACHERS AND OF
WORKFORCE.
DEVELOPERS I'M SERVING AT
PROMISE USE WE'VE DONE WORK WITH
OF LITERALLY THOUSANDS EDUCATED
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO AN
ESTIMATED THREE MILLION THAT
PROMISE STUDENTS. I WANT TO TELL
YOU ABOUT ONE STUDENT VERY
QUICKLY SO THAT YOU GET A SENSE
OF OF.
OF WHAT AT PROMISE MEANS I'M ONE
OF OUR TEACHERS MET OSCAR
COMPASS IN THE HOSPITAL AND. AT
LONG BEACH OSCAR HAD TAKEN TWO
BOATS HE WAS A GANG AFFILIATED
AND IT WAS OF LOOKS LIKE HE
WASN'T GONNA WASN'T GONNA MAKE
IT. AND OUR TEACHER SPENT SOME
TIME TALKING TO HIM ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOOKING AHEAD AND
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN HIS
LIFE. I'M OSCAR ENDED UP
ENROLLING IN OUR SCHOOL HE
GRADUATED HE.
HE FOUND THE TWO LOVES OF HIS
LIFE ONE IS STEPHANIE NIELSEN
ARCO WHOSE A WORKING ON A DEGREE
IN SOCIAL WORK RIGHT NOW. AND.
HE ALSO FOUND THAT HE LOVED
MATH HE GAINED A.
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND.
FROM CAL STATE LOS ANGELES AND
HE'S NOW TUTORING OTHER AT
PROMISE YOUTH AND WORKING ON HIS
TEACHING CREDENTIAL IT'S THE
MINDSET AND THE WAY THAT WE
APPROACH STUDENTS THAT REALLY
DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND WE.
STRONGLY SUPPORT A ACR ONE
NINETY SEVEN.
MISTER CHAIR PANEL GIVES THIS
YEAR FROM THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
YOU EVER SEE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
FIRST OF ALL WE'D LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
FOR HIS EFFORTS IN BRINGING THE
INCIDENCES OF.
CHILDHOOD.
ADVERSE EXPERIENCES TO THE
PUBLIC WE'VE ATTENDED A LOT OF
HIS INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND.
WE SUPPORT HIS A MEASURE.
HE'S ME I WASN'T RUNNING TO
COMMITTEE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT
SUPERINTENDENT DORRIGO AND A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS.
HAS TAKEN.
AN INTEREST IN THIS AREA AS AN
EDUCATOR. AND A SOCIAL WORKER.
AND SO FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WITH ME
MEMBERS.
IT'S YOU ANSWER WICHITA'S
RESPECT LAST THREE AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED
SOUND OUT OF SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ON ACR WHEN NINETY SEVEN THE
MISSION IS TO BE ADOPTED JONES
SAWYER ITEMS ARE AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO PATIO I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
KILEY THEM.
IT NOT LOW AYE I APOLOGIZE KILEY
NOT VOTING.
ETCETERA I'M JUST SIR I SEE THE
MISTER LOPEZ ARRIVED JUST
PROCEED WITH YOUR NEXT ITEM OR I
HAVE HIM OUT IF I COULD PROCEED
AND I THINK WE'LL GO JUST AS
QUICKLY ALRIGHT THIS YOUNG
MINDS.
ACR TWO ONE NINE.
HBO TWO ONE AYE RECOGNIZES JUNE
EIGHTEENTH AS SECOND CHANCES
MONTH IN CALIFORNIA THIS ACR IS
NEEDED TO EXPRESS. THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUCCESSFULLY
INTEGRATING THIS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. BACK INTO SOCIETY
IN ORDER TO PREVENT RECIDIVISM
AND BUILD STRONGER COMMUNITIES
CURRENTLY HAVE A CRIMINAL RECORD
IS A BARRIER TO OBTAINING
HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT RESULTING
IN THE MISSED OPPORTUNITY OF
ECONOMIC WELL BEING. AND A
BETTER LIFE ARE FAILED CRIMINAL
JUSTICE POLICIES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO ONE OF FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING INCARCERATION AS
RESULTING IN OVERCROWDING IN OUR
STATE PRISONS.
THE COST TO INCARCERATE ONE
PRISONERS TO LIVE A PRICE TO PAY
WHEN WE SEE RECIDIVISM DUE TO A
LACK OF REHABILITATION
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING MOVED
AVAIL AS CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY
I AM COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE.
WERE PROVIDED EVERY TOUR
RESOURCE AVAILABLE INCLUDING
GIVING THE FORMALLY CARS FOR HIS
SECOND CHANCE TO BE PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY. DOES A FEW
HOURS BROUGHT TO ME BY
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS QUESTIONS
AND DRAPE PERRY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK BROUGH.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIRST AND
FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO TAKE THE
THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER. AND AT THIS TIME HE IS A
TRUE CHAMPION OF THIS ISSUE I AM
ANDRE PERRY AND I AM THE POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. WE ARE PROUD
SPONSOR OF ACR TO NINETEEN WHICH
DOESN'T NEEDS JUNE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN A SECOND CHANCES MONTH
IN CALIFORNIA.
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS EXPOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO NUMEROUS
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES THAT
WILL FOLLOW THEM LONG AFTER
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF THEIR
SENTENCE.
THESE COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES
SERVICE SUBSTANTIAL LIFELONG
BARRIERS TO STABILITY AND SAFETY
FOR EIGHT THE EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE LIVING WITH
A CRIMINAL RECORD.
A RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT
SEVENTY SIX PERCENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION REPORT INSTABILITY AT
INSTABILITY AND FINDING A JOB OR
HOUSING IN OBTAINING LIENSE.
PAYING FOR FINES AND FEES AND
HAVING HEALTH ISSUES CALIFORNIA
TO NINETEEN WILL ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT MANY CALIFORNIA VOTERS
BUSINESSES CAN'T COMMUNITY
LEADERS LABOR UNIONS FAITH
LEADERS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION WANT SMART SAFE
SOLUTIONS THAT HIGHLIGHT
INTERVENTION. PREVENTION SECOND
CHANCES AND FAIR CHANCE
EMPLOYMENT OVER FELT TOUGH CRIME
ON POLICY WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND THANK YOU LEAST
STRONGLY AT MASS FOR NEITHER.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER JONES SAWYER PROJECT
BECAUSE EXPECT LAST WE ARE VOTE.
MOTION TO DO CLASS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
I'M ACR TWO ONE NINE THE MOTION
IS TO BE ADOPTED JONES SAWYER
AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO CAVIAR I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NOT BOATING QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT AND.
NEXT UP WILL BE EGR TWENTY
SEVEN BY MR LOW HIGH AND I WILL
BE RETURNING THE GAVEL THIS TIME
TO CHAIR JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS.
AND THE AGE YOU ARE TWENTY SEVEN
WITCHES COAUTHORED A BY NUMBER
OF MEMBERS INCLUDING MISTER
CUNNINGHAM AND MISTER LACKEY.
AS WELL AS MR BONTA MISS COOLEY
MISTER JONES SAWYER THIS IS A
SIMPLE WAY TO URGE THE. UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
TO DIRECT ITS ENFORCEMENT
PARTIES TOWARDS CALIFORNIA'S
LAUGHLIN CLOSELY REGULATE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
TO TO DO SO AND RESPECTING.
THE LAWS AND REGULATIONS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE A BY THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE AND OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE READY TO WITH AL
EVERYWHERE ANY WITNESSES TO
SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON BROWN WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AARON NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE GRIFFITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CANICE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION WE
DROP AND THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHER. ANY OTHER WITNESSES ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RT QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR.
LEADERS I'D WITH THE MOTION FOR
SECOND.
OKAY UP AND.
OBVIOUSLY I HAVE A GREAT
INTEREST IN THIS AND SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
.
IN THEIR CHAIRS RECOMMENDING AND
I.
CALDERON HR TWENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. CARILLO CARILLO AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES GRADUATE.
QUIRK AB TWO TWENTY TO FORTY NOT
VOTING.
GOOD THAT CONCLUDES THE.
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
AND FIFTEEN MINUTES THANK YOU